servers spawn 500 zombies and 500
skeletons
oh my god let's see who would win 500
zombies or 500 skeletons zombies are
just
bum rushing wait the skeletons are
shooting each other idiots oh
friendly fire oh my god it's not even
close zombies together strong
oh oh this is the last one as you can
see
the zombies were better by a little
let's go zombies
servers spawn another 500 zombies but
this time to a mutant skeleton wait what
is that
this is what i call mutant skelly oh my
god whoa
cheating gentlemen pick who you think
will win mutants kelly are 500 zombies
zombie gang mutant game gang carl pick
i'm on zombies i guess server drop the
glass let's see who is correct
oh oh my god what are you doing don't do
the punch move
oh my god yeah he don't care come on get
up
get up use your punch move it's more
damage oh he's
ruined he's a tank oh my god come on
zombie back into the corner yeah let's
go
ahead wait this actually might be close
oh
no we did it we did it
carl and chandler currently have one
point and me and chris have
zeros whoever has the least amount of
points at the end of this video has to
give away their couch
to a random subscriber what my couch
my couch has dog hair on it i just
bought a new couch
i'm not losing i'm in first on this side
will be a wither and on this side
500 bees i don't know about you guys but
i'm picking the weather i got bees
with their baby bees baby bees are
beating with their servers spotting it
let's go bees oh whoa whoa wait wait
look at them they're so adorable
oh he hit one i'm starting to change why
did i pick the wither are we losing look
these bees aren't even mad yet so they
don't all get wiped out by one attack
bees are smart bees are smart wither
don't die to bees come on do something
oh the health bar hasn't moved though
and while we're watching this weather
mercilessly slaughter bees i want you
guys to play along as well
oh here we go here we go here we go here
we go look at the damage yeah it's oscar
b
how is he healing so much wait he got
his health back what he got his health
back the reason why its health is going
up so much is because it regens when it
does damage
i just like bees okay oh he's in the
corner the bees are doing damage
turn around you idiot get off the wall
oh all the bees are on the wrong
side oh my gosh go bees go my cat loves
that couch i can't lose it
oh he's going spin mode oh my god he's
ain't fun
these are the last four bees all right i
got the child
i will feed him the child no oh he says
oh the child and with that the wither
won
me and chandler just got a point which
means chris is the only person not to
score so far
up next is 20 mutant zombies versus 20
mutant enderman
i'm going enderman's bobby i'm going
with enderman whoa look at those
endermen
it's gotta be enderman it's enderman did
i pick the wrong one look at them
what what are they doing the zombies are
so confused holy he just lost that dude
he's just chilling
taking a nap on the battlefield please
enderman this is for my couch
isn't it funny to think that these
mutant endermen have the fate of our
couches in their hands as well as giant
stone blocks apparently belly flop on
them come on get up
i'm gonna get close to them and listen
to their screeches
this is a haunt you it's looking like
the endermen are winning i could be
wrong oh
oh oh it happened so quick it happened
like
the blink of an eye poor guy poor guy
my couch is looking better oh
i'm two in one everyone has two points
except chris sadness
this next one is actually a brain teaser
one wither or 500 skeletons take your
pick i'm picking the wither because i
got screwed last time yeah i'm gonna
pick wither
i'm actually picking the skeleton we're
there screw it oh wait no
it's definitely gonna be the wither
you're going against your own logic that
you had that one time
because it regions when it does damage
oh darn it the bees had a better chance
you didn't see how dumb the skeletons
were when they faced the zombies
they're just owning them the skeletons
are killing themselves nerds
they literally are the weather hasn't
done a single damage yet just don't vote
for skeletons
at all skeletons are literally just the
stupidest thing in minecraft chandler
and carl are tied for first with three
me and chris are tied for last there's a
chance for my couch i'm doing this for
you baby my couch is now in jeopardy 100
blaze versus 500 snowmen all right pick
your side snowman
snowman i'm team blaze wait all three of
you grow in snowmen
yeah all right drop the gates let's see
what happens oh
my gosh oh snowmen are getting hit oh no
oh we messed up bad
i should have chose blaze they're
melting why do i twist chris it's like a
freaking war zone here wait we might not
lose yeah i think i might lose
fire go go go what it sounds like when
you're in between one million snowballs
oh we are gonna win it's not even close
it's not even close
what's the heck frosty the snowman just
saved my cow
fire melts snow no kill fire yeah
up next is a really hard one 1 000
zombies or
50 iron gold golems baby golems golems
column
all right i'm going zombies this is the
time i'm smarter than them yes let's go
start chucking them babies up they're
getting engulfed chris
they're taking a lot of damage quick
they're getting a goal they're hurting
each other they're hurting each other
he's getting a point oh the zombies are
so smart go yeah is that a boy
i don't want to lose my couch wait look
it's actually gonna be close i think i
got the dove
get out of here i hate you all i'm no
longer in last place i am now
tied for last place i honestly have no
idea what the answer to this next one is
10 giants or 1 000
skeletons your mind's like skeletons
right but they're stupid
oh my god i didn't mean to go to the
side come on giant baby wait so we're
all team giant i'm from new york okay i
gotta be a giants guy
the giants are just decoys ah they don't
even attack wait i was on the skeleton
side
no but wait will the skeletons just kill
each other oh god what the heck oh
one mutant creeper or 1 000 zombies take
your sides it's about the explosive
damage because if it blows itself up
it's all over i'm going with zombies
dips i don't know what a mutant creeper
is
i'm going zombies i'm going zombies i'm
gonna go zombies the creeper's done for
bro
oh my god he's watching about that
we all got it right but we're lame 100
skeleton horsemen or 1000 zombies one
thousand zombies thousand zombies
horsemen i'm picking horsemen chandler
me and you got this yes chris we got
this we got this we got this
i thought skeleton horsemen would have
like whoa
let's go baby oh you're done for it we
don't got this
we don't got this chris what was that
zeus just
blessing your couches right now yes
massacre
dude this slide show is amazing wait are
we gonna win
we actually might win this chris we're
gonna win chris look at me in the eyes i
want to be looking at you while we win i
don't even need to see it i know we're
gonna win oh my god turn around
last one he's dead we won i did it so
i am now in dead last again hey r.i.p
your couch buddy
50 snow golem or 1000 zombies bobby
i'm going with zombies oh wait wait we
might lose we might lose oh
dear god oh the massacre
i muted my headset i was so excited i
didn't know we were talking about this
kind of snow goal
they're like what are you doing you
slackers always trust in the zombies
zombies are open generally won what
about me i also won we don't stop
winning yeah we can't lose all right me
and chris are tied for last place
me and jimmy who's gonna lose our couch
500 llamas or 500 zombies
llamas llamas i i will give up my couch
to choose llamas i
trust my llamas i guess i'll go zombies
uh yeah i'm gonna go zombies why do
llamas look like that it's a coffee cup
oh my what are they gosh
are they spinning on the zombies the
power of spit even if we lose it's worth
because
i love my llamas so intertwined oh my
gosh it kind of looks like a country if
you look down oh yeah it does
whoa whoa i'm not seeing as much green
oh my god
oh my god no they're going off yeah love
us
love us wow
i'm in dead last i am now in last place
and chandler and chris are tied for
second to last yeah let's go
up next is 500 pillagers versus 500
zombies
fine i'll go zombies because i'm not a
chic they're skeletons but smarter
oh the zombies are dying that's right
that's what happens when you're not a
sheep i'm not a sheep i'm just dumb
car you're too far ahead leave okay the
three of us are tied for last place with
one more challenge left yeah we're all
losers together
pick your side before you even know what
it is yes no
no no no you guys paired against me
100 mutant zombies and 100 mutant
skeletons
oh no we got this up
all right i'll see you guys later i'm
gonna go figure out what to tell my wife
about the couch
all right drop the glass let's see what
happens no whoa
holy whoa there's arrows coming from the
sky
look at this look they bounce up and
they just shoot from the air that's
hilarious
oh he just dropped my man he just
dropped him it looks like the
skeletons are winning by a lot yes i
don't gotta get rid of my couch oh my
gosh look at the arrows
i deleted him chris got a point which
means now me and chandler
are tied for last place let's go chris
let's go
it is now me versus you 1v1 huh we don't
know what's going to spawn in each side
are you picking that side i guess so
here we go good because i wanted this
side
1000 zombies versus two mutant creepers
yo oh my god
you're about to lose your couch oh oh oh
and i don't see any zombies i'm so hurt
right now
chandler i hope you don't like your
couch because uh a random subscriber's
getting it
uh so i lost the challenge and i have to
give away my couch and i just need your
address so i can send it to you
oh my god